investigators turn to a genealogy
website to try to solve a young woman's
murder
eighteen-year-old Angie Dodge was killed
at her home in Idaho Falls the killer
left DNA at the scene but police could
not find a match for nearly two decades
in tomorrow's 48 hours Anna Marie Greene
investigates a controversial technique
police used to search for Angie's killer
the ability to kill is obviously
somewhere in all of us because it
happens every day across the country in
2014
Michael Ussery was living in New Orleans
trying to break in to the film industry
when I showed her body over in the
shower I just kept stabbing her with
this short film called murderabilia
murderabilia got me the reputation of
being a person who is really into murder
I'm a filmmaker who was a suspect in the
Angie dodge case andy dodge was murdered
last week the latest violent crime in
Idaho Falls has the officers arrived at
the crime scene it was obvious that
there was a very brutal murder that had
happened she was my only daughter I'll
never stop missing her Carol dodge
thought her daughter Angie's killer
would be caught quickly police had his
DNA a pristine sample says DNA expert
Greg Campion it's a single profile
complete identification one man to the
exclusion of everyone on the planet for
nearly two decades police couldn't find
anyone who matched the DNA so in 2014
they got creative and searched a public
DNA database owned by ancestry.com my
whole purpose is to find who killed
Angie Dodge armed with the DNA they hope
to find someone related to Angie's
killer they got a hit an anonymous man
who had once participated in a
genealogical study a warrant got them a
name it was Michael US Reese father
there are 34 out of 35
that match who wouldn't be you know
drawn to that with that many matching
DNA markers police were sure they were
in the right family tree so when they
found a son who was just the right age
they brought him in for questioning
I'd certainly didn't want to submit my
DNA for a murder case probably like most
people I just kind of buckled under the
pressure and and said okay nobody ever
thinks that they're gonna get picked up
by the police and taken into an
interrogation room and questioned about
a murder when it happens to you it it's
definitely a game changer
anne-marie green is with us now Ann
Marie good morning morning so the police
were able to access ancestries public
database that right yeah the key here
for this case is that ancestry.com
purchased a public database that was
already public right and so when police
were able to submit the DNA to that they
were able to sort of compare the crime
scene DNA to the public database after
this happened they made that particular
database private so that no one has
access to it or at least police don't
have access to it and that's the key
some databases are public some of them
are private so the public you don't need
a warrant but the private you gotta go
to want precisely right exactly and so
you know one of the things I think a lot
of people will wonder when they see this
story is hey you know I've submitted or
my mother has submitted I got it as a
birthday gift yeah should I be concerned
and the the two Biggie's are
ancestry.com and 23andme
I've done 23andme in fact that's how I
came to this story is after researching
it myself and the biggest thing that you
need to know is that these are private
databases so police will need a warrant
it's just that the one in this case was
public a lot of concern concern on the
part of consumers about where their DNA
is being used yes he's using it and
Marie thanks for that you can learn if
police found the killer by watching Ann
Marie's full report the DNA of a killer
tomorrow night on 48 hours it airs at
10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS